hello there you are watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with the
sunday times
chief foreign correspondent christina
lam and the conservative commentator
tim montgomery so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the mail reports that the final
loosening of lockdown will be delayed
until next month
their headline summer freedom on hold
till
july according to the telegraph rules
concerning mass
and social distancing will remain in
place beyond
june the 21st the sun urges
england football fans not to be
discouraged by the postponement
their splash reads shock and raw
while the mirror has seen figures which
suggest those fans will contribute
3 billion pounds to the uk economy
during the tournament
the ft leads with u.s president joe
biden receiving the support of his
fellow g7 leaders
in planning to shy away from austerity
and instead pursue
spending after the pandemic
but the times his relations between
boris johnson and his french and german
counterparts
are less harmonious with angela merkel
and emmanuel macron telling the prime
minister
they'll start a trade war with the uk if
he doesn't honor the post-brexit
northern ireland protocols
so with us tonight uh christina lam and
tim
montgomery to take us through the
headlines in the newspapers good evening
to you both
um let's start with the mail and um
their front front page
um july the the 19th uh they're looking
at
summer freedom on hold till july a new
date a new freedom day
is uh being proposed by them tim
yes well this is going to disappoint
many people especially in the
hospitality
sector but the government has looked at
some of the
impacts of the indian virus if we're
still allowed to call it that
delta virus i think it's now delta
variant it's now called
and they're worried about the rise of
infections
and they believe that with still quite a
number of people still to have
a second jab it's worth waiting a little
bit longer
in order for those people to be safe i
myself are very skeptical and
disappointed by this decision
i think we can wait forever and ever to
be completely safe
i think we've made such progress with
the vaccination
i think we need to get on with our
summer now and get on with our lives
because
it isn't just covered we need to be
protected from there's a huge backlog in
treatments across the national health
service
uh a lot of things that should be
happening normally in the world
in the education sector in the economy
aren't happening
and the risk of constantly protecting
ourselves against covid
but not getting on with the rest of our
lives just risks other problems
opening up and um i think people are
ready for their freedom so
overall i think this is a disappointing
decision by the government if it is
indeed confirmed
and next week christina what's your view
um should the the government be
more cautious or as tim is suggesting
that we need to get on with our lives
and go ahead with this
june the 21st date of unlocking
well i agree with him that people are
going to be very disappointed
because we all thought with so many
vaccines that
we were sort of on an escape pad to
normality
but you know the figures are quite
alarming if you look at the public
health england
figures i think they're saying 240
percent
increase in cases over the previous week
and also an increase in hospitalizations
my dad actually was just in hospital
last week because he'd had
a fall and you could see how short stuff
the hospitals
are so if they're going to be faced with
uh
another wave i think they're really
going to to struggle
um all the soundings are that because
we've had the the bma
come out this evening saying that that
date should be delayed tim that
boris johnson is really going to bow to
that pressure and the announcement on
monday
will be that the date is is pushed
forward
yes and i think of course when for
johnson and the government their weak
moment really was early in the pandemic
when uh they delayed the initial
lockdown
and then we had a huge rise in the
number of
elections and britain looked like for a
time that it had the worst
death toll in the western world really
per head of population
and that caused a real dip in the
government's popularity and a real
loss of confidence in the government and
i think that still
hangs over them to a great extent and
they they are worried that
maybe they will be forgiven by the
british voters to have made that mistake
once
but to have made that mistake twice some
would say three times given the
hesitancy over the lockdown last autumn
that that would be that would be too
much and
so that's the risk that they're focused
on
but as i say there are other risks there
is a huge
backlog of cancer treatments for example
many people in britain many more people
might die
from delayed diagnosis of their cancer
because of covid and will ever die
because of
its lockdown and because of covid but
the government won't be held accountable
in the
immediate term in the same way for that
and so unfortunately
the government has a set of incent a
sort of incessant
incentive structures which means there's
an over focus on covid
and a lack of focus on things like
cancer and i think it's producing
perverse decisions unfortunately
meanwhile uh christina the telegraph
um seems to have got the nod and there's
reporting as if the decision has already
been taken their headline june the 21st
unlocking
called off um as we sort of alluded to
earlier people really looking forward to
that date to regain some of their
freedoms
if they are curtailed do you think
people will adhere
to furthering restrictions continuing
restrictions
i think if it's just i mean they're
talking about delaying for four weeks so
i think most people reasonable people
would think well
i mean to jeopardize everything for the
sake of waiting four more weeks is not
really um a problem and you know
lots of things we have got back a lot of
normality already i feel sorry for
people waiting to get married because
obviously that's one of the things
that's going to be affected there's
supposed to be about 50 000 people's
weddings that were
due to happen that have been put on hold
and and this
decision means that the restriction of
only 30 guests still
continues i think there had been a
thought that the government might
give a special dispensation and and
waived that but the telegraph seemed to
think that's not going to happen
and tim it does seem um slightly odd
having interviewed people that are
uh having to to change their their
wedding plans or at least sort of
on the on the brink of deciding what to
do about invitations
um it's very odd for them when they see
mass gatherings uh going ahead
we had the pilot schemes in liverpool
the nightclubs the raves
and football matches that those can go
ahead safely and yet uh
a wedding for uh considerably fewer
people can't
absolutely do and i think it's the
contradictions in a lot of the policy
positions that really
you know will begin to annoy people and
of course watching
g7 leaders get in from all over the
world
for the summit in cornwall at the moment
not much social distancing
very few face masks there and so the
contradictions will begin to annoy
people
and i understand christine has just said
you know why
not wait another four weeks and it's
only another four weeks but of course at
christmas time we said give up christmas
so you can have easter give up easter so
you can have your summer
and now we're losing the summer
potentially as well so at some point we
have to say
enough is enough enough vaccinations are
out there
we've learned enough about this virus
and we need to get on with the rest of
our lives and
certainly people who are waiting for
their wedding ceremony
but i think be feeling that very
strongly indeed yeah indeed
you mentioned uh global leaders um
descending on cornwall
um let's talk about the the g7 and
president biden
apparently winning backing from uh
leaders to to carry on spending
this is in the ft christina
yes so well you've got this
i mean it feels as though this meeting's
been going on for days because there's
been discussion about it
actually started today um officially
and this rather bizarre photograph of
them all on the beach
socially distanced there was another
photograph too of them
walking onto the beach with this big gap
between them which looked rather like a
scene from reservoir dogs i thought um
almost all male of course and
um yeah so this is a really important
meeting because it's
um you've got a new president biden
saying that the u.s is back and a lot of
good will
because it's no longer president trump
who has sort of spent these meetings
trying to um often jeopardize the whole
thing he might remember the photograph i
think that was
2018 with the meeting where there was a
photograph of him
sitting opposite the leaders with his
arms crossed looking really angry
and angela merkel the german chancellor
uh leaning over him and so this is a
very different
vibe now a lot of good will a lot of
sort of
bonner me and people putting their arms
around each other and
as they shouldn't be of course during
and uh yeah so
a lot more cooperation and uh
but it is very important because as
everybody keeps saying
the one thing with this pandemic is no
one is safe until everyone is safe
and there is this discrepancy at the
moment that
um countries have got a vaccinating like
we are half our population now fully
vaxxed where as in
africa for example less than two percent
have had it yes
um and uh boris johnson describing uh
president biden as a breath of
fresh air it does seem to have a
different feel about it this this g7
meeting
um although it started uh very well for
boris johnson
there might be some trouble looming
around the corner
um when he has to have the meetings with
uh macron and angela merkel and
the times looking at that on their front
page tim
yeah and this is the uh sort of rumbling
issue
beneath the surface and that's you know
the the northern ireland
continuing northern ireland protocol
issue and
there's some optimism i'm sort of deeper
in that times article
with people noting that you know if you
compare the amount of
checks that are taking place on certain
goods going into northern ireland
there's three times the intensity for
example that is given two checks of
goods going into the eu via rotterdam
which is the biggest port of entry
for the eu so there does seem to be a
sort of a sense that the eu
is checking uh goods into northern
ireland to a degree
well out of proportion to what they do
normally
if only they were okay i'm sorry to
interrupt you we must leave it there for
this section we have uh
run out of time but we'll see you in a
second
uh coming up it may or may not feel like
it but is the economy
on the rebound we'll discuss that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview
still with me christina lamb and tim
montgomery um
let's have a look at the times uh
christine i haven't got a lot of time
left
um but really positive news um that the
economy returning to pre
pandemic levels yeah this is a
quite optimistic story saying that the
bank of england's predicting
7.25 growth which is the fastest rate of
growth since 1941 apparently
but you have to bear in mind that last
year we had a fall of 9.8
which was the biggest in 300 years so i
think we're
trying to remember since the great frost
of whenever
it was and we were
hit more than any other
of the richer countries so you know it's
um
good news and it's really because of the
vaccine of course that's enabled things
to
sort of open up and people start go out
and
spend all the money that they weren't
able to spend
last year although you know we of course
may
still have lots of people losing jobs um
as hospitality various things may be
forced to close so
i don't think we can be too um
optimistic about the future
uh but still so some good news and the
mirror um pointing to that as well in
terms of uh football fans
adding to the economy tim
yeah well i'm looking forward to doing
my bit jillian for the economy i'm not
gonna go to the up of course for my own
benefit or just to enjoy the football
and have a few beers
i will only be thinking about the
british economy when i buy that extra
pint
to toast the england football players
and after all the controversy we've had
over taking the knee over the last few
days
i think it'll just be good to get behind
the national team or the
team wherever you are do it for the
country i can't see your nose
i can't see your nose growing by the the
inch there
christina and tim thank you both